in their private yes episode don't cry
everything's gonna be here I didn't mean
what I said before I was just saying
well this is not good and he has Sarah
Garmin inside
[Music]
hey how's it going read my name it Oh
welcome back to some more heavy rain
there's that [ __ ] [ __ ] you ruin my
life
I was slacking no nothing yet but
they're gonna keep looking through the
night that's not gonna do anything you
know that right
do they do they think it's origami
correct
how the hell are that police I'm sorry
good yeah they don't know it's still too
early to say but it is a possibility
poor family the thing is how could you
guys don't you dare blame me you should
never have taken your eyes off him pain
for God's sake how hard is it to keep
your eye on the title or not
oh no she didn't wasn't it enough losing
day oh no she didn't
oh no she didn't yeah you better be and
then the museum
[Music]
hey hey don't cry don't don't worry I'll
find them I promise I'll find it
I've gotta find him
can't lose another son got a fine shot
or I'm just gonna start blend me guys
start lightly please they're doing oh
man [ __ ] hell
all right who are we gonna play us now
Scott Shelley be the man himself
I like his eyes I want to poke them with
a stick
what it's normal
totally normal Tuesday 952 I should say
oh it says the inches of the rain
because the victim gets drained in
rainwater so I guess it's ends yeah
anyway it's our character that we are
living good evening to you sir
all right it I want some condoms can I
help you sir well I hope so my name is
Scott Shelby I'm a private detective
I'm investigating the case of the
origami killer no uh I'd like to ask a
few questions maybe he's one of my son
is dead yeah mr. Shelby why is everyone
so I have nothing more to say
no one wants cooperate we could save
shot the killer has kidnapped another
victim a ten-year-old boy like your son
recent I have four days before we find
his body on a deserted stretch of
waistline no one did anything to save my
son now
you would please to why why is it on
such that's all I would per said you may
know something that could help save
other people's life I was unable to save
the life of my own son I do not see how
I could save the lives of other people I
guess that makes sense
I'll believe Oh do sell inhalers I'm all
outlet at least I won't go away
completely empty-handed in the back of
the store to the right
thank you that's convenient I'll just be
heading over there if the controls will
elect me not pizza
that makes me hungry whoops I didn't do
that
where are they here here thought for
sure I saw them huh oh can we snip
around
oh let's nipper oh never mind goddamn it
all right let's find inhaler it's really
difficult to control when the camera
angles changes all right there they are
good brand but these good evening sir
ah are you I didn't have for something
in particular
give me what you got in the registry oh
I can try anything
don't try stealth mode don't [ __ ] put
the money on the counter
oh [ __ ] you don't sniff
don't you [ __ ] register activate look
at the camera whoops hey you [ __ ] potato
soup you [ __ ] me all day I said come
here now I said I got it I got it
this is gonna be difficult this [ __ ]
don't move all right
all right you got me hands up put your
[ __ ] hands up or I'll shoot I'll have
to all right huh are you deaf I said put
your hands up alright alright I'm sorry
I'm sorry I don't wanna die oh shoot
yes yes yes don't get me so sorry I like
your hat calming down don't panic let's
just stay calm
nobody here wants to hurt you no we're
all just gonna be cool and everything
alright yeah so I I'm client yeah yeah
everything's gonna be all [ __ ] right
yeah yeah yeah oh I'm going closing Jim
and that's the reason why them look it's
not worth it
put the gun down and just walk away you
giving me advice yeah use some [ __ ]
advice
okay um what's your name buddy
my name is God what about you what's
your name Android my name's Andrew
cool name really cold night we want to
shoot anybody do you
I'm sure we can find a way out of this
mess right yep don't mind me coming
closer to you do you ever think about
what will happen a girlfriend maybe a
family yeah a little girl like a little
girl
ah Jessica what would Jessica think if
she saw you here yeah that's right
ask yourself what would happen to her if
things go wrong exactly
all right drop the weapon now now I want
you to put the gun back in your pocket
and quietly walk out of the store
my friend and I will forget about what
just happened and you'll have earned a
second chance not to [ __ ] up your life
huh what do you say
do it do it do it do it do it do it come
on come on don't do anything stupid what
[ __ ] it worked I should be like one of
those interrogators thing no yes
good boy good boy that's right that's
how we're all oh yeah anything that
lasts I know what would have happened if
you had not been here now you will have
to kiss this I didn't come by for
nothing
have a nice day when my boy mother
disappeared yes I received a letter with
a locker to get inside
inside the locker I found this box I do
not understand what it means but I think
it must be a sort of message from the
man who took my son from me hey Jenna
all right let's check it out maybe that
is that Oh what is this
please take the box if it can be of any
use to you at all it did not help me to
save Reza
but maybe it will help you find the
other little boy all right tip-top thank
you and then do it if there should be
yes tell me all about it
I will speak but I just think that there
was no good to be found in this place
hey I'm not afraid again that was pretty
impressive isn't it now
[Music]
hey what is her name I forgot well let's
see soon enough
this is the last character that we'll
introduce it's kind of slow story in the
beginning actually all through it but
it's worth it and I know a lot of you
bros are loving it already so hey I
think you can actually see boobs here
widgets which is interesting for some I
don't
I just don't think I can show it on you
Tim not that I want to see it anyway
[Music]
really like when girls have short hair
that much no kind of looks like a boy
it's my opinion it's nice and some
people but it kind of fits a character
the short hair all right let's get up
it's 3:00 a.m.
[Music]
get up thank you
[Music]
yay panties yeah
alright address where should we go let's
get naked
what is it done to stop
oh I go down here look zoom in bad shot
very classy and no clothes
don't make me laugh alright only thing
bad about this game is the camera angles
you make it makes you walk around like a
[ __ ] idiot
well it's really really hard to control
I don't think anyone really knows what
the [ __ ] they're doing let's go to the
fridge
so the music
I always open their bridge in this
[ __ ] stare at it it's pretty pretty
cool all right what else do we get a
lamp
no more surprisingly many lights outside
for being 3 a.m. it's funny point that
out there all right the bathroom is over
here boobies boobies boobies for wait oh
my god oh my god no
what a funny [ __ ] though I'm not
controlling what is happening what does
she do it oh no I'm not looking oh I
have to get naked okay come
it's not user friendly I sincerely hope
I remember to edit this out um I
covering the way all right but but what
are you doing here why do you why why do
you what oh boy I don't get it why did
have some new today I'm not complaining
sure a lot of people [ __ ] love this
shade it's like we just saw the
character and then she's naked eye yeah
yeah those are titties all right put on
panties I always wanted to do that never
done that before I swear I'd never wear
practice don't look at me like that all
right
so that was her if everyone is happy now
I'm sorry I probably have to censor that
because of YouTube I'm sure a lot of
people would love love to see boobies
but hey sometimes life gives u melons
and you just take them
you just think them in your face and
motorboat them that's how it is now
don't get me wrong I love some good old
boobies but I have a girlfriend and I
think she would be jealous if I stare at
boobies even though they're pixelated
I was that
heiped ow that sounds like a lame place
let's check the fridge again
we can't blame this boat around get up
some tea up [ __ ] sorry
[Music]
waiting for the te waiting for the tea
drinking that tea drinking that GE
alright there are stairs ah [ __ ] stairs
I like her apartment
it's nice who open the fridge
[Music]
this does not make sense at all I'm sure
it's nothing
no stupid fridge
why do you open your fridge what are you
up in yourself man you're not supposed
that is talking and saw what in hat
don't think I didn't say oh [ __ ] this is
no bueno mugged in Nevada there's
someone here yes there's someone in the
apartment Oh No let's go to mode
McKenzie I could call for help
ah the front door it's the only way out
if I can reach it I still have a chance
of what not getting you know in the
pooper I best get end this episode here
I'm not compared to the enjoy you don't
have to about you know it helps me
breath
[Music]